طلب مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه من
الامريكيين المساعده في التعرف على هذا
المقاتل الذي ظهر في احد تسجيلات تنظيم
داعش الشهر الماضي حيث انه كان يتحدث
اللغه الانجليزيه
بطلقه وعلى مدى هذه الاسابيع قام مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه باستخدام تطبيقات
ذكيه للتحليل الاصوات والتعرف على ملامح
الوجه وتعبيراته ومقارنه هذه النتائج
بالامريكي المشتبه بهم يعتقد مدير مكتب
التحقيقات الفيدراليه ان هناك العديد من
المواطنين الامريكيين يحاربون الان في
سوريا ولكنه يبدو اكثر قلقا حيال من يبدون
في موقع الاقل حذرا وهذا الجهد هو جزء من
حمله علنيه وواسعه لتعقب اي امريكيين
يسعون للانضمام لهذه الجماعات الجهاديه
وهنا ياتي في اعقاب الضجه التي احدث
اكتشاف شاب من شيكاجو لم يتجاوز عمره 19
عاما هذا الشاب محمد خان لم يكن من
المشتبه بهم ابدا حيث لم يرتب منه مكتب
التحقيقات الا قبل فتره قصيره
جدا بدون وجود بصمه القدم الالكترونيه ما
كان باستطاعتنا تصنيف محمد خان مشتبها به
يقول مكتب التحقيقات ان محمد خان كان على
اتصال الكتروني مع شخص يزعم ان باستطاعته
مساعده محمد للانضمام الى صفوف داعش في
سوريا ومنذ ان اعتقلت قوات الشرطه محمد
خان في مطار يو هارد الدولي السبت فالوقت
الذي تمتنع فيه عائلته عن التحدث
للصحافه واشارت بعض الاوراق في غرفته الى
انه انفق 4000 دولار لشراء تذكره ذهابا
وايابا تنقله من شيكاجو الى فينا في
النمسه ثم الى اسطنبول في
تركيا هذا يوضح لي انه كان يحول تجنب
اثاره اي شبهه حوله لذلك قام بشراء تذكره
ذهاب وعوده بدلا من ذهاب
فقط